John and Heather
[Music]
We Are the Champions can't say that
enough it feels good golden knights
waking up at Stanley Cup champions this
morning or still up from last night hard
to say more than 19 000 folks packed
T-Mobile Arena last night the largest
crowd in Golden Knights history I had
the pleasure of being there which was uh
I'm not I'm not I'm somewhere in that
area
[Applause]
morning after
all the celebrations went late into the
night what's next Lauren negrotti
joining us live near Caesars to show us
what the players and the cup got up to
last night Candace Charles joining us
outside of City National Arena we're
getting ready for some new Championship
merch but first Ron Futrell in studio
this morning and you've got a recap on
the big win love it right at the rally
towels okay from from last night by the
way gentlemen sweep is what it was that
means you let them win one game the
Florida Panthers and you win it in five
is what the knights did this was sort of
interesting last night coach Bruce
Cassidy starts five of the original six
they were called Misfits back in the day
the original Knights Marshall Riley
Smith William Carlson
Shea Theodore was in that mix along with
Braden McNabb William carrier also on
that team from 2018. can't start six
guys skaters at least a win by the
knights and the Stanley Cup is theirs or
ours Mark stone that goal gets better
the more I watch it fun goal right there
nice win going away 9-3 this one was
over early at this point it's all over
but the celebrating there was plenty of
that
here's a little bit of that fun skating
around the ice for the Vegas golden
knights this party this fun this
celebration is still going on around
town right now with the players I talked
to some of them after the game
I don't know how much I'll remember
about the hockey itself but I'll
certainly remember this group and the
memories that that we've shared through
you know throughout this year and you
know the ones that we're going to make
later on this week
you can't re recreate this feeling you
can't you know why this okay all right
thankful for for everyone that's helped
me along my journey too right and you
know a lot of us hockey players and
people in the sport we don't get here
without our support systems this is feel
for you it feels amazing I mean their GM
was the one that traded me here I guess
it's kind of come full circle uh it
feels great I mean you look at all the
loved ones out here this is the best
fair in the world and we're gonna
remember this forever not only being in
history on this thing but with one
another it's the best getting their
names on the cup as promised here's
Chandler Stevenson his wife and little
one okay
of course and get those pictures of a
great moment right there with the guys
and congratulations the cup the cup by
the way is heavy 35 pounds oh oh I got
the chance they said Ron you want to
lift it I said no why would I want to do
that out on the ice oh so I did okay of
course and the picture on the left is
Denver 1990 national championship by the
rebels and I do want to make this point
here with this at how this town is
United the feeling that we all have with
the championship it was like that those
locals that have been here for a long
time remember 1990 when the rebels won
it all against Duke a blowout win yes
that still stands historic with 30-point
win last night a blowout
wins yeah if we make this a tradition we
can live with that yeah
sooner this team's going to be good for
a long time folks yeah they're solid
it's amazing they're Synergy last night
how about a World Series win in five
years okay
also Chris Matthews